HEARING THIS MORNING FOLLOWED BY
THE BUSINESS OF THE DAY WE
ACTUALLY HAVE ONE BILL BEFORE
ASSETS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND WITHOUT ANY OBJECTION.
IF THE SECRETARY WILL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
OKAY WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE WILL WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND THE CONSENT ITEM IS
SB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
DEALING WITH ANIMAL WELFARE SO I
THINK WE CAN GO AHEAD AND GO
INTO THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
THIS MORNING ON INDUSTRIAL HEMP
AND AS ALWAYS IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE OR QUESTIONS.
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO ASK IF
YOU COULD FILL OUT A CARD PLEASE
ON WITH OUR SERGEANT WHO'S IN
THE BACK -- AS YOU KNOW THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FEDERAL FARM
BILL LEGALIZED THE PRODUCTION OF
INDUSTRIAL HEMP IN THE UNITE
STATES BY AM REMOVING IT FROM
THE LIST OF SCHEDULED ONE
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
THAT ARE REGULATED UNDER THE
FEDERAL CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE ACT
AND REDEFINING IT AS AN
AGRICULTURAL COMMODITY.
BUT EVEN BEFORE THE PASSAGE OF
THE FEDERAL FARM BILL CALIFORNIA
HAS BEGUN THE PROCESS OF
LEGALIZING THE PRODUCTION OF
INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA INDUSTRIAL HEMP
FARMING ACT IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN THE ACT BECAME
EFFECTIVE ON JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN UPON THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR BY THE VOTERS.
AS DIRECTED BY THESE NEW LAWS
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE ESTABLISH
THE HAMP ADVISORY BOARD TO
ADVISE THE SECRETARY AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ALL MATTERS.
PERTAINING TO INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
TODAY WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE THE
CALIFORNIA HIM COUNCIL AND A
GROWER TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
AND UPDATE THE COMMITTEE ON THE
PAST.
PRESENT AND FUTURE OF GROWING
INDUSTRIAL HEMP I CALIFORNIA.
OUR FIRST PANELIST TODAY ARE
RACHEL O'BRIEN.
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS AND JOSHUA KRESS
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAM MANAGER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE BUT
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO ASK MY
VICE CHAIR SCOTT WILK IF HE
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE I WOULD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
IN YOUR OPENING YOU FORGOT OUR
BILL THAT WE DID THAT IT UPDATED
POSTS OPERA OF SIXTY FOUR THAT
PUT IS IN COMPLIANCE SO WE
IMPORTANT LINK IN THAT.
AND I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
I DON'T NORMALLY TO COME TO
THESE KIND HEARINGS BUT I'M AT
THIS HEARING.
BECAUSE THIS GOOD I THINK
REVOLUTIONIZE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE AND ACTUALLY WE'RE
GOING BACK TO OUR FUTURE --
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS.
THE SALES OF THE NINA THE PINTA
AND THE SANTA MARIA ALL MADE OUT
OF HAND.
THE CAULKING IN THE BOTTOM OF
THE BOATS MADE OUT OF HEMP.
THOMAS JEFFERSON DRAFTED THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE ON
HIM PAPER BETSY ROSS WAVE THE
WE'VE THE FIRST AMERICAN FLAG
WITH HIM.
SO ALL WE'RE DOING IS REALLY
GOING BACK TO OUR FUTURE I'M
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS --
INTERESTED TO HEAR WHAT OUR
PRESENTERS GONNA PRESENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITHOUT
WE WILL GO AHEAD OF CALL UP OUR
FIRST PANEL [inaudible] FIFTY
MANY ARE THESE
.
I KNOW ANY [inaudible]
CONTENT.
PLEASE THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIR GOOD MORNING VICE CHAIR
RACHEL BRIAN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE AND THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS.
AND I JUST THOUGHT I'D GIVE A
JUST A BRIEF OVERVIEW -- OF THE
DEPARTMENT -- DEPARTMENT FOOD
NAG IS STATUTORILY CHARGE TO
SERVE THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA.
BY PROMOTING AND PROTECTING A
SAFE HEALTHY FOOD SUPPLY.
AND ENHANCING LOCAL AND GLOBAL
AGRICULTURAL TRADE THROUGH
EFFICIENT MANAGEMENT INNOVATION
IN SOUND SCIENCE WITH A
COMMITMENT TO ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP AND WE'RE REALLY
HONORED AND PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY. TO TALK ABOUT INDUSTRIAL
HEMP AND THE WORK THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN DOING ON
THAT FRONT.
I'M AT THIS POINT ALTERNATE OVER
TO JOSHUA CRASS WHO CAN
INTRODUCE HIMSELF AND KICKING
BACK.
GOING TO GO INTO A PRESENTATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- SON JOSHUA KRESS I
AM DIRE BRANCH CHIEF FOR OUR
PASSES LUJAN RANTED CDFA ALMOND
WITHIN OUR BRANCH ONE OF OUR-MANY PROGRAMS IS INDUSTRIAL
HAPPENS WILL BE PROVIDING KIND
OF AN OVERVIEW OF THE PROGRAM
AND I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE.
ABOUT THAT AS WE GO THROUGH --
SO THE FIRST WHETHER WE HAVE
HERE TODAY -- IS A SLIGHTLY
RECENTLY PRESENTED TO THE STATE
BOARD OF AGRICULTURE IT'S SIMPLY
TIMELINE OF HOW WE'VE GOTTEN TO
WHERE WE ARE LEGISLATIVELY WITH
REGARDS INDUSTRIAL HAVE -- SO IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AS YOUR
LIKELY WHERE -- WE HAD THE
CALIFORNIA SO HAVE FARMING ACT
SB FIFTY FIVE SIXTY SIX IT WAS
PASSED THAT ESTABLISH DIVISION
TWENTY FOUR THE FEAR CULTURAL
CODE.
OF AND ALSO DEFINED INDUSTRIAL
HEMP IN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE -- HER HAD A PROVISION AT
THE END OF THE BILL AND THE END
OF THE LAW THAT SAID THAT SHALL
NOT BECOME OPERATIVE IN LESS
AUTHORIZED UNDER FEDERAL LAW --
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THERE
WAS THE TWENTY FOURTEEN FARM
BILL OF THE FEDERAL AGRICULTURAL
ACTIVE TWENTY FOURTEEN WHICH
PROVIDED.
FOR PILOT PROGRAMS -- FOR
INDUSTRIAL HEMP AND RESEARCH BE
CONDUCTED BY -- COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES -- IN WITH
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARDS TO ADD
AS A CALLED RESEARCH ON
INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN OF THE
ADULT USE OF MARIJUANA ACT PROP
SIXTY FOUR AMENDED DIVISION
TWENTY FOUR THE FEET ARE
CULTURAL CODE. TO REMOVE THE
UPPER PROVISION AND TO SIMPLY
STATED IT THE LAW WAS EFFECTIVE
AS OF JANUARY FIRST -- TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND MADE SOME
OTHER MINOR CHANGES THROUGHOUT
THE BILL ARE THROUGHOUT THE LAW.
AND THEN LAST YEAR WITH TWO
MAJOR CHANGES ONE THAT OCCURRED
HERE -- THAT'S BUTTE FORTINO --
NINE WHICH MADE SOME SEND A
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES -- TO
DIVISION FIVE FOR THE FINANCE
CULTURAL CODE INCLUDING ALLOWING
COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH OUR OWN
FEES -- ALLOWING CDFA TO
ESTABLISH TAMPLIN TESTING
PROCEDURES -- AND THEN ALLOWING
CDFA TO ESTABLISH ARE VOLATILE
PILOT PROGRAM -- AS AUTHORIZED
IN THE TWENTY FOURTEEN FARM BILL
AND THEN REQUIRING ESTABLISHED
AGRICULTURAL RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS AS DEFINED IN THE
LAW TO NOTIFY THE COUNTY
AGRICULTURE COMMISSIONERS PRIOR
TO PLANTING -- SHORTLY AFTER THE
BILL WAS SIGNED THEN -- THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN FARM BILL WAS
PASSED WHICH INCLUDED --
SUBSTANTIAL PROVISIONS WITH
REGARDS TO INDUSTRIAL HEMP AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL I REMOVED HIM
FROM THE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
ACT I'M SURE YOU'LL BE HEARING
MORE ABOUT THIS FROM PATRICK
LATER.
ON ALL THREE STATES AND TRIBES
TO REGULATE INDUSTRIAL HEMP
CULTIVATION A A REQUIRES USDA TO
ESTABLISH NATIONAL A NATIONAL
REGULATION REGULATORY PROGRAM --
AND THEN ALSO ALLOWS FOR THE
INTERSTATE MOVEMENT OF HAPPEN
AND PRODUCTS -- INSIST BRIEFLY
HOW WE GOT TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY
SO AFTER THE THE CHANGES THAT
WERE MADE TO PROP -- VIA PROP
SIXTY FOUR IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN SEE IF
ESTABLISH THE INDUSTRIAL AND
PROGRAM.
WAS ESTABLISHED WITHIN THE PLAN
HEALTH AND PASTOR VENGEANCE
SERVICES DIVISION AND IS
OVERSEEN BY THAT DIVISIONS
NURSERY SETON COTTON PROGRAM --
CULTIVATION AND CULTIVATION OF
INDUSTRIAL -- IS GENERALLY
SUBJECT TO THE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS OF OTHER
AGRICULTURAL COMMODITIES EXCEPT
THE DIVISION TWENTY FOUR ALSO
REQUIRES REGISTRATION
CULTIVATION SITES WITH THE
COUNTY OF CALL TO COMMISSIONER.
AND TESTING OF EACH CROP -- FOR
TEACH THE CONTENT -- AND THE
REASON IS PLACE WITHIN THE
NURSING CON PROGRAM IS THAT IT
IS IN SOME WAYS SIMILAR TO OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALREADY OVER
SEEN THERE. FOR INSTANCE NURSERY
LICENSING -- SEED REGISTRATION
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE TO GET
LICENSED OR REGISTERED AND
OURSELVES A FEW PRODUCTS OR
SEEDS -- WE COLLECT FEES
MANAGING THE MANAGING VISOR MORE
THINGS THAT NATURE -- ENTER
CURRENTLY THIS PROGRAM HAS -- TO
FULL TIME STAFF MEMBERS -- IN
THIS IN THE PROCESS OF HIRING A
FEW MORE MITCHELL ADDRESS A
MINUTE -- IN THEIR PROJECTED
EXPENDITURES FOR THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR ARE THREE UNDER
NINETEEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
TWELVE DOLLARS -- BUT THAT
INCLUDES AN ENCUMBRANCE OF FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
PLANNED COUNTY CONTRACTS AS WE
GET GOING WITH REGISTRATION --
SO IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN OF THE BACK A LITTLE
BIT ROM WHERE REFER STARTED --
THE THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
WE'VE DONE WHICH AGAIN TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT A SECOND IS
THAT WE PROPOSED TO DOT SECTION
FORTY NINE HUNDRED IN TITLE
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA CODE OF
REGULATIONS.
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH A
REGISTRATION FEE -- WE ALSO
ADOPTED TO OTHER REGULATION
SECTION FORTY AND TWENTY FOUR
AND TWENTY ONE WHICH ESTABLISH.
A AN AMENDMENT TO THE APPROVED
THE LIST OF C. CULTIVARS THAT
ARE LISTEDIN THE FEW NARROW
CULTURAL CODE AND THEN ALSO
ESTABLISHES A PROCEDURE TO MAKE
FURTHER CHANGES.
AS THE DEPARTMENT LOOKS TO MAKE
CHANGES TO THE LIST OF FRIDAY
MAY BE GONE CALIFORNIA -- IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE HIRED A
SENIOR MAMMAL SCIENTIST AND WE
ALSO SUBMITTED A BREAK BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL. FOR UP TO SIX
TOTAL POSITIONS -- STARTING IN
FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY I'M ALWAYS
JEALOUS INDUSTRIAL HEMP ADVISORY
BOARD AND JOE IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AT THIS POINT
THE WORD IS SOLD TEN OF BOARD
MEETINGS IN ONE TASK FORCE
MEETING.
A WE'VE HAD DURING THAT TIME TO
MID TERM VACANCIES THAT WE'VE --
HAD TO FILL -- THE TERMS FOR
BOARD MEMBERS ARE THREE YEARS SO
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY WILL BE
HAVING.
A NEW OPENING A NEW OPENING
THERE AND POTENTIAL TURN OVER
FOR THE BOARD -- WE'VE DEVELOPED
AND PRESENTED APPLICATION
TEMPLATES -- THERE IS IN
ADDITION TO THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING IN CALIFORNIA WE DO WORK
WITH OUR PARTNERS -- IN OTHER
STATES NATIONWIDE -- WE'VE DONE
THAT THROUGH THE NATIONAL
INDUSTRIAL HAVE REGULATORY
CONFERENCES SET UP I BELIEVE IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN OR SO -- AS
IT WAS INITIALLY LED BY THE
STATE OF KENTUCKY BUT AT THIS
POINT IS A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
AMONGST ALL STATES TO TRY.
TO HARMONIZE AND COMMUNICATE
REGARDING THE COMPLEXITIES OF
TRYING TO REGULATE INDUSTRIAL
HEMP IN THE U. S. -- SOURCE
STAFF WERE ABLE TO ATTEND IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND ARE
PLANNING TO ATTEND AGAIN IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TO CONTINUE
THAT HARMONIZATION COLLABORATION --
WE DEVELOP THE RANGE OF PUBLIC
OUTREACH MATERIALS ON OUR
WEBSITE -- INCLUDING A EXTENSIVE --
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS
SECTION AND THEN OF COURSE WE
HAVE CONTINUOUS RESPONSES -- TO
PUBLIC INQUIRIES IN COORDINATION
WITH OTHER AGENCIES REGARDS
INDUSTRIAL HAVE -- WE DO GET
FREQUENT FROM FREQUENT AT
INCREASING THE PUBLIC REGARDING
THIS TOPIC.
SO FOR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE
HAVE NOW.
CHECK MULLIN FOR QUESTION PLEASE
SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO I WANT
TO KNOW WHAT THE STATUS WAS OF
REGARDING THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS BECAUSE IF THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN PRESENTED GREAT IF
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN PRESENTED I
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN ONCE
EMITTING A LETTER TO TESTIFYING
IF POT IF I'M AVAILABLE.
A DAY YOU CAN USE I CAN TAKE
THAT.
THE SUN.
IT IS CENTER WILL THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION YES BOTH OF BOTH
HOUSES HAVE HEARD RBC P. IN THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE -- AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE SENATE WILL BE
PICKING THAT UP THIS THURSDAY --
AND ONE OTHER CLOSE OUT MEETINGS.
OKAY GREAT THANK WE WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE ANY SUPPORT
FROM THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- SO MOVING ON TO
WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'VE DONE SO
FAR IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO ACCOMPLISH --
SO FIRST OFF THE REGULATION --
THAT WE PROPOSED FOR THE
REGISTRATION FEE -- SECTION FOUR
HUNDRED WAS APPROVED -- JUST
LAST WEEK AND IS EFFECTIVE IN IN
PLACE AS OF APRIL TWENTY FIFTH --
SO WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
THE COUNTY OR CULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS TO IMPLEMENT
REGISTRATION STATEWIDE INCLUDING
ESTABLISHING A MEMORANDUM
UNDERSTANDING WITH ON THE
COUNTER CULTURE COMMISSIONS AND
SEALERS ASSOCIATION --
ESTABLISHING SCOPES OF WORK IN
CONTRACTS WITH EACH OF THE
COUNTIES -- PROVIDING TRAINING --
AND SO WE'VE BEEN OUR STAFF HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THAT EXTENSIVELY
ESPECIALLY OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS AND THAT WAS PASSED.
ON WE ARE ANTICIPATING THAT IN A
PRESS RELEASE SHOULD BE OUT SOON
AND THAT THOSE APPLICATIONS WHEN
THEY'RE AVAILABLE -- WILL BE
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE -- SO
THE WEB APPLICATION BE OBTAINED
THREE CDFA BUT AS A SPECIFIED IN
LAW THE REGISTRATION ACTUALLY
MADE WITH THE LOCAL COUNTY
AGRICULTURE COMMISSIONERS.
AND SEVERE COORDINATING THAT
EFFORT WITH THE CAREFUL TOOK
MEASURES IN A BY A MORE STAFF
YOUR DAY BUT THEY'RE BUSY ON THE
PHONE WITH THE COUNTIES.
AND WITH OTHERS TRYING -- TO GET
ALL THAT ROLLED OUT AN ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND THINGS THAT NATURE --
FURTHER ACTIVITIES FOR THIS YEAR
SO WE WILL BE -- PROBABLY
GETTING ADDITIONAL REGULATIONS --
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS A FEW
OUTSTANDING TOPICS -- MOST
IMPORTANTLY SAMPLING AND TESTING --
AS I MENTIONED CENTER FORTINO --
NINE ALLOWS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO ESTABLISH SAMPLING AND
TESTING RELATIONS TO BE FLEXIBLE
AND BE ABLE.
TO PUT IN PLACE SOMETHING WAS
GOING TO WORK FOR CALIFORNIA
GROWERS IN COMMISSIONS THAT ARE
GONNA BE ENFORCING THESE RULES
SO -- WE ARE GOING TO BE WORKING
ON GETTING THOSE REGULATIONS OUT
AND PROPOSED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE --
SO THAT WE CAN GET -- A
GUIDELINES IN PLACE FOR THE THE
CURRENT CROP SEASONS THAT WAY --
GROWERS CAN RECEIVE THE SAMPLES
THAT THE TESTING -- SERVICES
THAT THEY'RE GONNA REQUIRE --
WILL ALSO BE WORKING ON
REGULATIONS -- INFERENCE WITH SB
FORTINO NINE FOR AN ANKLE SO
PILOT PROGRAM.
AND THEN -- WE'RE ALSO EXPLORER
AND EDITION REGULATIONS WITH
REGARD TO STAB LIST AGRICULTURAL
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS AND
FURTHER SPECIFY HOW THEIR
INTERACTIONS ARE -- DEALT WITH
WITH THE CHEMICAL TO
COMMISSIONERS -- FOR THE
REQUESTED BCP WILL ALSO BE
LOOKING TO HIRE ADDITIONAL
PROGRAM STAFF I'M CURRENTLY AS I
MENTIONED WE HAVE TWO STAFF
MEMBERS THAT ARE HIRED --
ESSENTIALLY WERE BORROWING A
COUPLE POSITIONS ON WE'RE
LOOKING TO BORROW A COUPLE MORE
HOME THAT HOPEFULLY RECEIVING
THE POSITIONS THAT WE REQUESTED --
AND SO WE WILL TRY IT WE'RE
TRYING -- TO RAMP UP OUR
STAFFING A LITTLE BIT TO BE ABLE
TO BETTER SERVE THE CANTICLE
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS AS
THEY ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM IN
THIS LAW -- WILL CAN OF COURSE
CONTINUE TO COLLABORATE WITH THE
CHEMICAL AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS -- AS IT WE'RE
ROLLING OUT A NEW PROGRAM WE RUN%
INTO ALL SORTS OF NEW AND
UNEXPECTED -- INCIDENTS AND SO
WE WILL ALLOW WE HAVE EIGHT
MAINTAIN RY TO MAINTAIN AT
LEAST AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AN
OPEN LINE OF COMMUNICATION WITH
THEIR COUNTY PARTNERS -- IN
TRYING TO ADMINISTER THIS BE
CONSISTENT STATEWIDE -- HER
STAFF DO YOU PLAN TO ATTEND THE
TWENTY NINETEEN NATIONAL
INDUSTRIAL HEMP REGULATORY
CONFERENCE WHICH I BELIEVE IS IN
EITHER JUNE OR JULY -- IN
MINNESOTA -- WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING AND WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS AND OTHER STATES IN AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WITH REGARDS
TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN FARM BILL AND
HOW.
THE DEPARTMENT WILL BE --
IMPLEMENTING THOSE REQUIREMENTS
AND SUBMITTING OUR STATE PLAN
ONCE REGULATIONS ARE AVAILABLE
AND THEN -- WE WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP ADDITIONAL
OUTREACH MATERIALS AS I
MENTIONED WE GET LOTS AND LOTS
OF QUESTIONS.
AND AS WE START TO BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP MORE AND MORE ANSWERS WE
CAN TRY TO GET MORE -- PROMOTION --
OUT REACH MATERIALS OUT THERE TO
THE PUBLIC INTO THE COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH FURTHER
GUIDANCE AND FURTHER INFORMATION
ON HOW DO.
IN MINISTER IN FALL OF THIS LAW
[inaudible]
CHECK [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK.
I HAVE A COMMENT THIS TIME SO I
I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR EFFORTS IN
TERMS OF HAVING OPEN
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE AG
COMMISSIONERS ARE WE HAD AND ONE
OF MY COUNTIES WE HAD A A
COMMISSIONER THEY CLEARLY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WAS GOING ON AND YOU GUYS
DID A PHENOMENAL JOB WITH ABOUT
FORTY EIGHT HOURS -- GETTING IT
ALL HANDLED SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR GUISES EFFORTS
ON THAT SO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IT'S GOOD HERE THANK YOU -- SO
OUTSIDE OF THE VISION -- TWENTY
FOUR WE DO HAVE A FEW OTHER
REGULATORY CONCERNS WITH REGARDS
TO INDUSTRIAL HEMP CULTIVATION --
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THE THE
OTHER OF LAWS AND RULES -- THAT
APPLY TO OTHER AGRICULTURE
MONIES TO APPLY TO YOU AND US ON
AS WELL -- SO WE HAVE CONCERNS
AND WE ARE KEEPING AN EYE OUT
FOR THESE PARTICULAR ISSUES --
NEW PESTS AND DISEASES FOUND ON
HAVE BEEN CANNABIS -- AS THIS IS
A RELATIVELY.
NEW AGAIN CROP -- THEIR RESEARCH
IS JUST NOW BEGINNING ON AND
BEGAN AS FAR AS WHAT PESTS AND
DISEASES WILL -- AFFECT.
CANNABIS PLANTS AND SO WE ARE --
YOU MAINTAINING AGAIN
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR WITH OUR
SITE IN BOTH OUR INTERNAL
SCIENTISTS AS WELL AS AND WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
TRYING TO KEEP AN EYE ON THOSE
THINGS AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT.
WE EXPECT WILL PROGRESS GREATLY
OVER THE NEXT YEAR TWO YEARS
FIVE YEARS AT CETERA -- IN ORDER
TO SELL HEPPNER SHE'S TALKING
LICENSES OWNERSHIP STOCK IS
REQUIRED IMAGE IN ADDITION TO
THE OTHER INDUSTRIAL HEMP REYES
I REGISTRATION REQUIREMENTS --
WE ARE CURRENTLY EVALUATING --
THE APPLICATION CALIFORNIA C.
Là TO THE SALE OF INDUSTRIAL
HEMP AND THAT SALE AND MOVEMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL HEMP SEEDS -- WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL APPLY WE
LIKE WE NEED TO PURSUE
REGULATIONS ARE TO FULLY APPLY
THE COMFORTING Là IT IS
CURRENTLY ADDRESSED IN THE
FEDERAL SEAT ACT -- SO THERE'S
PRECEDENT THERE AND SHOULD BE A
HOPEFULLY SIMPLE CHANGE UNDER
THAT IS SOMETHING WE WORKING ON
THIS YEAR -- WE HAVE RECEIVED
BROAD INTEREST IN ORGANIC
CERTIFICATION AND WE ARE
ACTIVELY TRYING TO WORK WITH
OURS A STATE ORGANIC PROGRAM.
ON TRYING TO ADDRESS THE THE
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS OF THEIR
RECEIVING AND TRY TO COORDINATE
WITH THEM WITH REGARDS TO
ORGANIC CERTIFICATION AND ASSIST
ANYWAY WE CAN -- THERE IS ALSO
INTEREST IN THE SALE OF HEMP IN
HEMP PRODUCTS AT A CERTIFIED
FARMERS MARKETS AND THAT
SOMETHING'S BEING --
INVESTIGATED FURTHER BAR
INSPECTION SERVICES DIVISION.
AND THEN THERE ARE CERTAINLY
OTHER PROVISIONS IN THE FEED
THEIR CULTURAL CODE THAT MAY
HAVE POTENTIAL IMPACTS WITH
REGARDS INDUSTRY HAPPENED SO
WE'RE CONTINUING TO EVALUATE --
AND AS I MENTIONED WE FIND NEW
AND INTERESTING SITUATIONS
ALMOST EVERYDAY.
I HAVE  QUESTION SO ARE THEIR
LICENSEES THAT THAT CURRENTLY DO
HAVE LICENSES TO SELL NURSERY
STOCK.
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY -- WITH
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
RELATIVELY NEW -- WITH THE THE
CHANGES IN THE FEDERAL FARM BILL
THE KIND OF OPENS THINGS UP A
BIT MORE FOR DEFINING.
AND AS AN AGRICULTURAL COMMODITY --
AND SO WE MADE IN THE PAST WE'VE
WE CERTAINLY WE USED TO RECEIVE
A LOT OF APPLICATIONS FOR
CANNABIS GROWERS ESPECIALLY BACK
BEFORE PROP -- SIXTY FOUR THAT
I'M NOT AWARE OF WHAT OUR OUR
NURSERIES ARE CURRENTLY GROWING
I KNOW IF I'VE HEARD.
PERSONALLY FROM -- SOME OF OUR
EXISTING NURSERIES THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN MOVING INTO
INDUSTRIAL HEMP SO I ANTICIPATE
THAT THERE WILL BE SOME BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF WE CURRENTLY HAVE
AND OKAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR CAMPERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
I I HAVE -- A QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO THE FRAMEWORK THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT -- AND
WE'RE REALLY WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW CAMPAIGN TO
REALLY FOCUS ON IT BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS.
DEFINED IT AS AN AGRICULTURE
PRODUCT IS THAT.
KIND OF THE BASE FROM WHICH WE
THEN MOVE OFF OFF OF SO.
CALIFORNIA HAS ITS OWN
INDUSTRIAL HEMP CLOSER GROWERS
ARE REQUIRED TO FOLLOW -- SO WE
CERTAINLY ARE WORKING WITH --
COLLABORATING WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS TO TRY TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF FEDERAL LAW --
THAT ABSOLUTELY IMPACTS THE
INTERSTATE MOVEMENT OF HELP --
AND SO AND THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING WE'RE ACTIVELY WORKING
ON HOWEVER WE'VE AS IMAGE WE
HAVE HAD A WE'VE HAD AN
INDUSTRIAL HEMP LAW IN PLACING
IN CALIFORNIA FOR MANY YEARS NOW --
ZURICH ON ADMINISTERING OUR OWN
OUR OWN LAW AND CERTAINLY
WORKING WITH OUR COLLABORATES
RY -- TO DO WHAT WE CAN.
TO HARMONIZE AND COLLABORATE
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS AND
TRY TO APPLY A FEDERAL LAWS WELL
AND MAKING SURE THAT YOU KNOW.
OUR GROWERS ARE ARE PROTECTED IN
AWARE OF THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS
THAT MAY BE APPLIED TO THEM.
WELL I THAT THAT MAY ANSWER THE
QUESTION I GUESS I'M.
WE'RE SETTING UP THIS BIG
FRAMEWORK THAT.
THAT LOOKS LIKE IT MAY MAYOR
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH MARIJUANA
BUT HIM TO REALLY.
DIFFERENT PRODUCT AND AND SO I'M
I JUST WANNA.
I WANT TO CAUTION US -- EITHER
IT'S AN AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT.
AND AND WE CAN SET UP -- SOME
FRAMEWORKS THAT DON'T REQUIRE
OVER REGULATION OR WEALTH OR
ELSE WE'LL WE'LL SET UP THIS
WHOLE FRAMEWORK WHERE YOU'VE GOT
TO GET A LICENSE TO DO ANYTHING
AND I JUST WORRY ABOUT THAT --
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT HEMP
IS DIFFERENT THAN MARIJUANA
CERTAINLY IT'S GOT -- SOME REAL
PRACTICAL APPLICATIONS THAT MAY
ALLOW US -- TO USE IT IN WAYS
THAT.
WARRANT WARRANTY INITIALLY
DESIGNED FOR HIM RIGHT WE IT IF
IT USES LESS WATER HOW MUCH LESS
WATER IF IT -- IF IT CLEANS THE
SOIL -- IT MAY HAVE SOME
APPLICATION FOR AGRICULTURE IN
THAT REGARD AND IF IT CAN BE
MANUFACTURED INTO PRODUCTS THAT
ARE USEFUL AND THAT CAN REPLACE --
PLASTICS FOR EXAMPLE THERE MAY
BE A HUGE MARKET FOR HEMP AND WE
WOULD BE IN A IN A PRETTY UNIQUE
POSITION IN THAT REGARD SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
BEFORE WE GO DOWN THIS ROAD WERE
LICENSE ANY.
LICENSING THE SEEDS LICENSING
THE PLANT LICENSING.
THE PROPERTIES THAT ARE GROWING
AT THAT WE LOOK AT WHAT.
A FRAMEWORK THAT GIVES US A
LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY THAN
THAN MARIJUANA AND MARIJUANA.
OBVIOUSLY IS A DIFFERENT IF IF
IT'S A DIFFERENT SUBJECT AND WE
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT LICENSING
BUT BUT I'M I'M JUST NOT SURE IN
IN THIS INSTANCE SO.
JUST PUT THAT OUT THERE YEAH IF
I COULD ADDRESS THAT -- THANK
YOU FOR THAT FOR THE COMMENTS
AND LIKE AND THE AND LAYING OUT
SOME OF THE COMPLICATED
STRUCTURES THAT WERE WORKING
THROUGH -- CURRENTLY.
HEMP IS IN FOOD ENACT CODE
THEREFORE IT IS AN AGRICULTURAL
COMMODITIES INDUSTRY DID SUCH
JUST LIKE THE REST OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED COMMODITIES -- THAT ARE
GROWN AS AGRICULTURAL YOU KNOW
COMMODITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- AND WHAT.
STATE LAW HAS CURRENTLY DIRECTED
US TO DO IS TO SET UP A
REGISTRATION PROGRAM FOR HIM --
WE DO NOT ISSUE A LICENSE AND
REGISTRATION DOES TAKE PLACE --
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL DOWN WITH
THAT COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS -- I THINK WHAT
JOSH WAS REFERRING TO IN TERMS
OF OF NURSERIES THEY DO HAVE TO
GET CERTAIN LICENSES TO BE ABLE
TO TO SELL PRODUCTS -- BUT IS
CURRENTLY NOT THE INTENTION OF
THE DEPARTMENTNOR WE STATUTORY
REQUIRED TO DO ANY LICENSING --
FOR HIM CULTIVATORS AND
DIFFERENT FROM CANNABIS NEW
CANNABIS WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE AS
AN AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT YOU KNOW
VERY DEFINED SEPARATE AND
DIFFERENT AND THAT'S THAT'S HOW
WE'VE BEEN APPROACHING IT FROM
THAT KIND OF LANDS -- AND IN
TERMS OF BEING A LAYING OUT THE
FRAMEWORK CURRENTLY WE'RE NOT
STATUTORILY DIRECTED TO TO ME --
WHAT CANNABIS IS DONE?
AND SO COURT WE YOU KNOW WE PLAN
TO STICK WITH THAT WITH THAT
PASSED [inaudible]
YEAH.
BUT THAT'S ABOUT ALL THAT I'VE
GOT SO -- THE LAST COUPLE SIDES
HERE TO SIMPLY HAVE OUR CONTACT
INFORMATION -- SO FOR THIS
PROGRAM -- WE HAVE SET UP A
GENERAL EMAIL INBOX TO TRY TO
STREAMLINE AND SIMPLIFY THE
ABILITY FOR THE PUBLIC TO GET A
HOLD OF US.
AND WE DO HAVE A WEBSITE --
WHICH HAS RECENTLY BEEN UPDATED
TO HEAR THE REST TO SEE THE
OF OUR LAW REGULATIONS -- AND
AND THE VERY NEAR FUTURE IF IT'S
NOT UP ALREADY WILL ALSO HAVE A
COPY OF OUR APPLICATION -- AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL OUR REGION
INFORMATION FOR CONSUMERS FOR
GROWERS FOR ON THE COUNTIES AS
WELL TO TRY -- TO I NAVIGATE
THEIR WAY THROUGH THIS LAW -- SO
WE ARE AGAIN OUR STAFF TO
RECEIVE REGULAR QUESTIONS FROM
THE PUBLIC AND I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE ASSISTANCE WE GET
NOT JUST FROM.
THE REST OF THE OTHER PROGRAMS
WITHIN OUR EIGHT OUR OWN AGENCY
BUT ALSO FROM OTHER AGENCIES AS
WELL -- TO TRY TO NAVIGATE SOME
OF THESE OTHER ISSUES A DIVISION
TWENTY FOR THE FUTURE CULTURAL
CODE ADDRESSES CULTIVATION
HOWEVER WE HAVE QUESTIONS ON
ANYTHING INVOLVING HAVE NOT JUST
ON THE CULTIVATION PRACTICES AND
SO.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE ASSISTANCE
WE GET FROM FROM OUR PARTNERS
ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE -- AND
THAT'S ALL THAT I HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU TO
BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS DO WE HAVE ANY
FINAL QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
NOW OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
HOPE YOU'LL JOIN US FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE HEARING.
OUR SECOND PANEL IS DEALING WITH
GROWER PERSPECTIVE ON INDUSTRIAL
HEMP WE HAVE TAYLOR MOTION
DIRECTOR OF COMMODITIES AND LAND
USE FROM THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION.
AS WELL AS DAVID ROBERTI OWNER
OF LIBERTY BRANCH.
THANK YOU.
HEY WE COULD JUST TAKE ONE
MOMENT I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
QUORUM IF THE SECRETARY COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS GALGIANI THE JOURNEY
HERE WILL PRESENT WILL PRESENT
CABALLERO.
CABALLERO HERE GLAZER.
AND WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW SO WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND HERE SB SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN IS ACTUALLY ON
CONSENT [inaudible]
SO.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO CONSENT
SENATORS GALGIANI.
I GALGIANI I WILL WILK AYE
CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE GLAZER.
HE WILL GO AHEAD AND KEEP THE
WALL OPEN FOR THAT AND IF OUR
PANELISTS WOULD GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED AND I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS TO THE RUSSIAN WITH A
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU WE JUST
WHEN I START BY SAYING THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CONVENING THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
WE KNOW IT HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS
CHANGE IN THE LAST THREE YEARS
ARE FOUR YEARS WITH INDUSTRIAL
HAVE POLICY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND FEDERALLY.
I'M IN ANY OPPORTUNITY WE CAN
OFFER -- TO ARE CALIFORNIA
FARMERS TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO BE -- INNOVATIVE AND TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A NEW AGRICULTURAL
COMMODITY WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT OPPORTUNITY
SO WE'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
WILL FOR HIS BILLS WHILE.
I'M AND I HAVE WITH ME DAY FOR
BIRDIE HE AS A FOURTH THIRD
GENERATION -- RANCHER AND OFF A
GROWER I'M FROM PLUMAS SIERRA
COUNTIES I'M AND SO I'M GONNA
LET HIM LEAD AS THE AS THE
GROWER EXPERT ON THE STAND HE
THANK YOU MISTER BERNIE THANK
YOU.
THAT SOUNDS A LITTLE
INTIMIDATING BE THE CORE EXPERT
YEAH BUT THE YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING
ME TO COME TODAY AND AND DRESS
YOU -- FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
OF A FARMER -- WHEN I MET UP
WITH TAYLOR THIS MORE AND I SAID
I DIDN'T ASK ABOUT DRESS CODE
COULD I HAVE JUST WORN MY OLD
DONALD COVERALLS OR WHAT AND HIS
NO YOU'RE FINE BUT THE ANYWAY SO
I'M A LITTLE OUT OF PLACE WITH
MY JACKET ON BUT -- I AM.
PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE THAT I SEE HIM
BECOMING FOR CALIFORNIA FARMERS --
I AM OF THIS TAYLOR MENTION I AM
A THIRD GENERATION FARMER I'M
HERE TODAY WITH MY WIFE AND MY
DAUGHTERS IN THE AUDIENCE -- AND
SHE WRAPPED HER THAT REPRESENTS
THAT FOURTH GENERATION -- THE
WANTS TO STAY ON THE FORM.
BUT AGRICULTURE IS PROBABLY MANY
OF YOU KNOW IS GOES THROUGH SOME
REAL CYCLES IN HARD TIMES AND
PART OF THOSE TIMES ARE HITTING
NOW FOR SOME -- SECTIONS OF
AGRICULTURE.
AND TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE ON
FARMING -- CHANGES NEED TO BE
MADE SOMETIMES IT'LL GET A
LITTLE MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT OUR
OWN PERSONAL SITUATION IN JUST A
MOMENT.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE THREE
GENERATIONS WORKING ON OUR
FAMILY FARM -- WE GROW ABOUT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED ACRES OF ALFALFA
UNDER -- PIVOT IRRIGATION AND
ALSO RUN ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED BEEF
CATTLE ON OUR ON OUR OPERATION
IN OUR OPERATION START NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO WITH MY GRANDPARENTS.
AND IT'S BEEN OUR FAMILY EVER
SINCE AND IS COMPLETELY FAMILY
OWNED AND OPERATED -- WE LIVE --
HANG IN A LITTLE BIT OF SOME
WHAT DO A LOT OF PEOPLE REALLY
CONSIDER BEAUTIFUL COUNTRY AND
YET -- IN IT IS BUT IT'S SOME
PRETTY HARSH COUNTRY TOO SO WERE
UP IN THE IN THE SIERRAS JUST
NORTH THE TRUCKEE CALIFORNIA
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE MILES AN
ELEVATION OF FIVE THOUSAND FOOT --
BEAUTIFUL VALLEY -- BUT IT
CREATES ITS OWN CHALLENGES IN
THAT -- BECAUSE OF OUR CLIMATE
AND VERY SHORT GROWING SEASON
AND CALL COLD SEASON AND SO WE
CAN GET FROST ANY DAY OF THE
YEAR.
AND YES I'VE EVEN SEEN SNOW ON
THE FOURTH OF JULY -- BELIEVE IT
OR NOT -- LAST YEAR WE HAD MADE
A DECISION OUR FAMILY -- TO
REALLY TAKE A BIG JUMP OF FAITH
AND OUT OF OUR COMFORT ZONE AND
TO US.
TRY PLANTING SOME HAMP -- THE
MAIN REASON FOR THAT IS BECAUSE
OF OUR DECISION MAKING WAS
BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
ALTERNATIVE CROP -- IN OUR
SITUATION GROWING OFF ALPHA. FOR
MOST OF OUR MARKET GOES TO
DERRY'S IN THE MODESTO TURLOCK
AREA AND IN DERRY MARKET IS
REALLY BEEN HURTING LAST SUMMER
YEARS A LOT OF DAIRIES GOING OUT
OF BUSINESS.
pAFFECT OUR MARKET AT SOME POINT
TWO AND WE DECIDED IT'S TIME TO
START LOOKING FOR ANOTHER
ALTERNATIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO OUR CLIMATE
AVOCADOS DON'T WORK TOMATOES
DON'T WORK ALMOST NOTHING CAN
STAND THE COLD WEATHER THAT WE
HAVE.
AND THEN WE RAN ACROSS HIM.
AND THAT LAST YEAR WE DID PLANT
SOME.
UNDER THE PROGRAM WITH THE
UNIVERSITY IN ABOUT AT ARENA ON
DR -- GLENN MILLER WHO WAS THEY
WERE EXCITED ABOUT ONE
APPROACHING ABOUT DOING RESEARCH
FOR US.
BECAUSE NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
NORTHWESTERN NEVADA.
HAVE VERY SIMILAR CLIMATE AND
DRY.
LOW PRECIPITATION ON THE SIDE OF
THIS YEAR AS AND AND KIND OF
COLD COUNTRY AND SO HAVING --
BECAUSE WE'RE JUST FROM ABOUT
FORTY MINUTES FROM RENO AND HE
WAS EXCITED THAT HE COULD JUST
HAVE A SHORT DRIVE TO COME DO
THE RESEARCH -- WITH HIS -- WITH
HIS STUDENTS -- SO WE LOOKED AT
HIM LAST YEAR WE DID PLAN SOME
AND I WOULD NOT CALL IT A
SUCCESS AT ALL.
WE HAVE A WE LEARNED A LOT
THROUGH OUR FAILURES AND I THINK
THAT'S GONNA TAKE PLACE
THROUGHOUT -- WITH THE FARMERS
BECAUSE IT IS A NEW CROP -- BUT
THROUGH THAT LEARNING WE LEARNED
THAT IT IS POSSIBLE IN OUR AREA --
THAT HIM HANDLE TEMPERATURES
DOWN INTO THE MID TWENTIES.
IT DIDN'T LIKE THE EIGHTEEN
DEGREES FOR MORNINGS IN A ROW IN
THE FIRST WEEK OF SEPTEMBER HAND
SO THAT WE DECIDED IT'S TIME TO
HARVEST.
AND THE HEAD OF IT -- TO BUT IT
DOES HANDLE THE COOLER WEATHER
AND SO.
I'M NOT CONVINCED YET THAT IT'S
GOING TO WORK FOR US.
BUT OF THE VERY VERY FEW CROPS
THAT CAN GROW IN THERE I THINK
THIS IS A REALLY HAS THE
POTENTIAL.
THE OTHER PART THAT REALLY
EXCITES ME IS THE POTENTIAL OF
WHAT THIS CROP CAN DO AND I'M
NOT GONNA GET INTO ALL THE
DETAILS OF CENTER HERE WAS
TALKING ABOUT MAKING PLASTICS
AND FIBER BOARDS AND EVERYTHING
BUT IT REALLY IS ENDLESS I THINK
ALMOST WITH THIS PLANT CAN DO.
A LOT OF THE HYSTERIA AND HYPE
AND EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW IS ALL
BASED AROUND CBT OILS AND
DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S GREAT.
BUT I THINK THERE'S GONNA BE A
LOT MORE ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
START GETTING TO THE PROCESSING
OF THE FIBER AND THE USES THAT
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
PLACE THERE I THINK THAT'S WHERE
THE REAL FUTURE IS GOING TO BE.
OUR RESEARCH WITH THE UNIVERSITY
IN ABOUT AT ARENAL.
BILL WITH A FIVE AREAS LAST YEAR
AND WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE OUR RESEARCH HOPEFULLY
FOR IF IF THINGS GROW ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE THAT FOR
FIVE YEARS -- THIS WILL WE DID
NOT GET INTO THE THIS RESEARCH
JUST TO GIVE US A LICENSE SO TO
SPEAK TO TO GROW HAMP WE REALLY
WANT TO DO THE RESEARCH AND SO
WE'VE GOT A IVE YEAR AGREEMENT
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF NEVADA
RENO.
THE BIGONE WE WERE TO COME IN
THERE ALL BIG BUT THE WATER
CONSUMPTION IS A BIG ONE
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR AREA WE ARE
IN A MOTOR ITS OWN AS FAR AS OUR
OUR WATER BASIN HAD AND THE THE
PROBLEMS YOU CAN HAVE THEIR WE
BELIEVE THAT THE WATER.
CONSUMPTION WILL BE PROBABLY
ABOUT A THIRD OF WHAT ALFALFA
YES -- INSECT PREDATION -- WE
DON'T KNOW NEW WEEVILS CROSSOVER
FROM ALFALFA -- TO HAMPER AND SO
WERE WERE DIDN'T WERE STUDYING
THAT.
PLANT SPACING FOR OPTIMAL YIELD --
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION HOW
FAR APART YOU NEED TO PUT THE
PLAN SIR TO THE YOU KNOW IF IF
THEY NEED TO GET ROOM TO GROW OR
DO THEY DO BETTER -- CLOSER
TOGETHER.
PLANT VARIETIES TO TO FIT OUR
CLIMATE -- IT'S LIKE ANYTHING
ELSE -- YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE
RIGHT VARIETIES TO HANDLE THAT
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING INTO THAT.
AND THE OPTIMAL TIME TO HARVEST --
SO THAT REQUIRES TESTING.
EVERY FOUR FIVE DAYS ONCE YOU
GET TO MATURITY POINT SO WHAT IS
THE OPTIMAL TIME TO HARVEST --
AND TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OF OF
THE CROPS BEST DEAL.
I THINK CAMPUS.
HAS BECOME AN WILL BECOME THAT
CROP THAT HELPS US.
FIND THE VIABILITY FOR A LOT OF
FARMERS NOT JUST IN OUR AREA AND
THROUGHOUT NORTHEASTERN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
THAT BY ABILITY TO STAY IN
BUSINESS.
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE OF SO MANY SECTORS IN
AGRICULTURE THAT ARE STRUGGLING.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH A TOMATO --
TRANSPLANT COMPANY.
AND TO SEE IF THEY CAN AND THEY
THINK THEY CAN TO SEE IF THEY
CAN MODIFY THEIR EQUIPMENT. TO
PLANT SEEDS OF HIM TO START THEM
PLANTS AND THEN ACTUALLY IT
TRANSPLANT THEM JUST LIKE DOING
TOMATOES -- THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES THERE THE SIZE OF
THE PLANTS GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
THAN A FEW DIFFERENT THINGS.
BUT IN TALKING WITH THIS
GENTLEMAN IS A VISITOR AT OUR
PLACE -- LAST WEEK -- HE'S
EXCITED ABOUT GETTING INTO THIS
NEW VENTURE ALSO.
BECAUSE WHAT'S TAKING PLACE IN
AND TOMATO INDUSTRY THAT I
DIDN'T KNOW IS THEIR SCALING
BACK TO THEY'RE GOING THROUGH A
HARD TIME HE LOST OVER A
THOUSAND ACRES THAT -- THAT THEY
PLANTED LAST YEAR AND SO HE'S
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING
ABLE TO STRUCTURE HIS BUSINESS
TO TO HELP US OUT TO KEEP HIS
EMPLOYEES.
AND TO KEEP HIS BUSINESS GROWING.
THERE A LOT OF THINGS THAT --
AND CHALLENGES AHEAD BUT BEING A
NEW CROP WE EXPECT THAT AND WE
FOUND THAT OUT LAST YEAR --
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO PLANT
USING SEEDS ARE USING CLONES --
WE'D AN INSECT CONTROL IS GOING
TO BE A BIG ONE BECAUSE THERE'S
THERE'S NO REGISTER PESTICIDES
OR HERBICIDES AVAILABLE ON HIM
YET -- AS WELL AS WELL AS THE
THE BEST WAY TO HARVEST THAT IS
ONE OF THE REAL QUESTIONS THAT
ARE STILL OUT THERE THERE'S A
LOT OF DIFFERENT IDEAS AND
MODIFICATIONS TO EQUIPMENT BUT
THERE IS NO ONE WAY YET -- OF TO
HARVESTING IN FACT A LOT OF IT
IS STILL DONE -- BY HAND AND
THAT'S WHAT WE DID LAST YEAR --
BUT THE FARMERS WILL FIGURE OUT
A WAY.
I'VE GOT NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT
THEY'RE PRETTY.
GOOD AT INVENTING THINGS AND
MODIFYING THINGS -- PROCESSING
PLANTS ARE LAGGING BEHIND A
LITTLE BIT AND THAT'S EXPECTED
BECAUSE I CAN EXPECT SOMEBODY GO
BUILD A MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
PROCESSING PLANT BEFORE THIS
PRODUCT.
AND SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
CATCH -- TWENTY TWO AND SO NOW
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A THE
TIME LAG THERE TO GET THINGS
PROCESS TO WHERE DO YOU GO WITH
IT -- BUT I THINK OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE THREE YEARS THAT WILL ALL
GET EVENED OUT AND THE
PROCESSORS WILL COME -- BUT WITH
THE CHALLENGES ALSO COME.
WITH A NEW CROP -- ALSO COMES
OPPORTUNITY AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE REALLY NEED TO BE
LOOKING.
FORWARD.
AT WHAT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES ARE --
FOR US THE OPPORTUNITY IS.
HOPEFULLY PROVIDING A VIABLE WAY
FOR OUR OPERATION TO STAY IN
BUSINESS SO ARE FOR GENERATION
FIFTH GENERATION WHATEVER
FARMERS -- OR FAMILY CAN STAY ON
THAT LAND -- BECAUSE YOU BEGIN
TO WORRY ABOUT OKAY OF ALFALFA
MARKET GOES AWAY.
WHAT WE DO NOW BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF OPTIONS? TO SELDOM
THAT A NEW CROP COMES ALONG.
WITH THAT.
CAN REALLY GET EXCITED ABOUT --
WHEN I WAS I WENT TO HIM
CONFERENCE BACK IN DENVER A FEW
WEEKS AGO?
AND THIS GUEST SPEAKER THERE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME THING HE
SAYS YOU KNOW THE LAST BIG CROP
THIS COUNTRY IS REALLY SEEN THAT
REALLY CHANGING THE SOYBEAN.
AND I WAS TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO.
I THINK HIM AND HE THOUGHT SO
TOO I THINK HIM HAS THE ABILITY
TO BE WAR WAY BIGGER THAN
SOLVING CROP -- WHAT WE CAN DO
WITH IT -- SO ANYWAY I'VE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME I'LL ANSWER
ANY KIND OF QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE FOR ME AND IF -- WHEN WE
GET INTO THE SEASON IF SOMEBODY
WANTS TO COME TAKE A LITTLE TOUR
WE'D LOVE TO HAVE INVITED TO
COME SEE OUR PLACE SOME?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DID HAVE A
QUESTION -- IN TERMS OFTHE
WEATHER WHEN IT'S WHEN WE HAVE
LATE RAINS.
AND YOUR CROP GETS WET AND THEN
YOU HAVE THE SUN COMING AND IS
THERE A CHANCE FOR MORE THAN
WHAT DOES THAT DO TO YOUR CROP
WHEN YOU HAVE LATE RAINS.
YES -- MILDEW IS AB IT CAN BE A
BIG PROBLEM FOR HIM -- AND
PROBABLY OVERSTEPPED AMOUNT
OVERSTEPPING MY BOUNDS OF
KNOWLEDGE HERE BUT THE THERE
THERE'S A CONCEPT THAT HAMS
GONNA JUST GROW ANYWHERE -- AND
I DON'T I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE CASE -- HIM DOES
NOT LIKE REALLY HOT WEATHER IT
JUST KIND OF SHUTS DOWN DOESN'T
GROW WE'RE WELL -- HIM DOESN'T
LIKE HIGH HUMIDITY.
SO THERE ARE CERTAIN AREAS OF
THE STATE THAT PROBABLY IS NOT
GOING TO WORK REAL WELL TO BE
GROWING HIM.
BUT THE ONE THING YOU DO WANT TO
TRY TO CONTROL IS THE HUMIDITY
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO GET SOME
RAINS AT THE WRONG TIME -- AND
IT COULD CAUSE YOU SOME PROBLEMS
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
HARVESTING IS IS GOING TO BE THE
REAL TRICK THERE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT WAYS NOW THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING A HARVESTING SOME OF
THEM CUT THE HAMPER AND THEN
LEAVE IT ON THE GROUND FOR FOUR
FIVE DAYS TO DRY.
AND THEN COME THROUGH WITH SOME
EQUIPMENT -- TRY THIS --
SEPARATE THE LEAVES IN THE BUGS
FROM THE STOCK AND STUFF.
THAT PUTS YOU KNOW DANGER ZONE
THOUGH AWHILE IT'S SITTING ON
THE GROUND TRYING TO DRY --
THERE'S OTHER -- METHODS COMING
ABOUT IT SEEMS LIKE THAT -- YOU
CAN CUT IT -- AND MEDIA THE
HOLLOW IN THE TELL PROCESSING
WILD GREEN EVEN SO -- ALL THAT'S
GOING TO COME WITH PEOPLE
FIGURING OUT HOW TO DO A BIT YES
MILDEW CAN BE A VERY BIG PROBLEM
FOR FOR HIM YES.
AND WHAT ABOUT IF YOU HAVE A AN
EARLY FREEZE WHATEVER CROP
FREEZES.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT YET -- WHAT
IT WHAT OF MY ENTERED WHAT I'VE
STUDIES SO FAR IN RED IS HIM
EVEN AS A IS A A SEEDLINGPLANT
CAN HANDLE FROST PRETTY WELL --
WHATWE'RE GOING TO DO THIS YEAR
BECAUSE WE CAN STILL GET FROST --
UP TO NOW THE END OF MAY AND
INTO THE FIRST PART OF JUNE WORK
FOR GONNA PLANTING ABOUT THE
FIRST OF JUNE -- WE ARE GOING TO
PLANT -- IN IN ROSE BASICALLY
WITH PLASTIC DOWN -- AND THAT'LL
HELP WITH SOME RADIANT HEAT FROM
THE SOIL FOR THE CEILING PLANTS --
AND WE THINK THAT'S GOING TO
HELP US A LITTLE BIT IN CASE WE
DO HIT ARE REALLY COLD NIGHT --
BUT IN INTERVIEWS AND GRIPPER
OCCASION AND SOUL THERE ARE
THINGS THAT WE CAN ALTER A
LITTLE BIT TO HELP WITH THAT BUT
YES FROST IS A REAL CONCERN FOR
US -- ON THE ONE THING THAT.
HAS BEEN A REAL STRUGGLE FOR US
BECAUSE IT IT'S ALSO VERY -- HI
INVESTMENT CROP RIGHT AT THIS
POINT.
VERY HIGH -- YEAH YOU CAN SPEND
TWELVE FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
AN ACRE VERY EASILY -- TO TO GET
IT IN AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS
IS REALLY CONCERNED -- SO WAS
AND AS OF RIGHT NOW THERE IS NO
CROP INSURANCE AVAILABLE -- FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT FOR FROST
FOR RAIN -- FOR HAIL -- AND SO
IS THE MAKES CRINGE A LITTLE BIT --
MY WIFE -- SHE HAS BEEN HOUNDING
SO A COUPLE DIFFERENT INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND WE'VE FINALLY.
FOUND THE ONE THAT WILL GIVE US
A SOME.
CROP INSURANCE IN THE SENSE OF A
AND EVENT INSURANCE IF WE GET A
MASSIVE HAIL STORM OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THAT THEY WILL -- THEY
WILL COVER IT SO THAT THE BETH
THE ONLY INSURANCE COMPANY WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DIG UP SO THAT
GIVES US A LITTLE BIT OF RELIEF.
TO KNOW THAT OUR INVESTMENT IS
PROTECTED TO SOME EXTENT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR
WELKER WHY NOT -- WHAT WERE YOU
GET YOUR SEATS FROM?
THESE ARE COMING FROM -- TO
DIFFERENT PLACES SOME SOME
COMING OUT OF COLORADO THIS YEAR
AND AND SOME OTHERS COMING OUT
AND ABOUT IT WE'RE WE'RE GONNA
PLAN FOR DIFFERENT WE'RE GONNA
DO TWENTY ACRES IS ALREADY DOING
THIS YEAR -- AND RENEW FOR
DIFFERENT VARIETIES THERE --
THAT WE'VE BEEN WILL WORK FOR
THE GENTLEMAN LAST YEAR AT OF
FALLON NEVADA THAT THEY'VE BEEN
GROWING FOR ABOUT THE LAST THREE
YEARS OR FEELS JUST LOOK
BEAUTIFUL -- AND HE HE'S KIND OF
GUIDED ME IN THE DIRECTION OF
VARIETY AS FAR AS THE THE MOST --
FROST RESISTANT AND AND HEARTY
PLANT AND SO WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
THREE OR FOUR FOUR DIFFERENT
VARIETIES THERE TO TO SEE HOW
THEY DO.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY AT THIS POINT
YOU NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
GROWS PASSED IN YOUR
MICROCLIMATE BEFORE YOU CAN
FIGURE AYE AND THEN YOU WERE
GOING TO FIND PEOPLE TO BUY IT
AFTER THAT RECORD RIGHT NOW YOU
JUST KIND OF BETA TESTING RIGHT
YES WE ARE BETA TESTING RIGHT.
NOW SO.
I WOULD LOVE TO AND IT'LL TAKE
YEARS OF COURSE TO DEVELOP SEED --
AND THAT'S WAY BEYOND MY SKILL
SET BUT I WOULD LOVE TO DEVELOP
SEE THAT FITS OUR CLIMATE AREA
YOU KNOW IF WE CAN FIND
SOMETHING THAT CAN HANDLE FROST
DOWN. TO FIFTEEN DEGREES BOY YOU
CAN.
IT ALL DAY LONG YOU KNOW --
ACROSS THE NORTHEASTERN PART OF
THE STATE -- BUT IS SO THAT
THAT'S KIND OF A LONG RANGE GOAL
RIGHT NOW IS ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S SOMETHING AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW THAT CAN GROW -- THAT
WE WON'T LOSE OUR INVESTMENT ON
AND NOW AND AND HOPEFULLY START.
TRANSITIONING FROM IN SOME
ALFALFA WERE CERTAIN I AM
PLANNING ON GOING ALL THE WAY
OUT BUT TRANSITIONING TO SEE IF
IT'LL WORK OUT WELL.
I APPRECIATE YOUR VISION AND I
SHARE IT AND I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE
AN ENTREPRENEURIAL RISK -- I
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO PAY
DIVIDENDS FOR YOU SOME VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
ANYBODY ELSE IN THIS ROOM IS
INTERESTED WE ARE HAVING A
CEREMONY AT ELEVEN AM IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE NFL IN FRIDAY
MAY SEVENTEENTH.
WHERE WE ARE GOING TO BE DOING
ARE FIRST PLANTING -- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS FORBES
MAGAZINE'S GOING TO BE THERE IN
NEW YORK TIMES IS GOING TO BE
THERE -- CAL EPA DIRECTOR
CHAIRED BLUMENTHAL'S GONNA BE
THERE NOW HAS TO COME WITH A
NINE NOW STATE SO NOW HE'S
LOCKED IN -- AND IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED YEAH GET BACK TO ME
AND I WILL MAKE SURE YOU GET AN
INVITE TO TWO TANKS I THINK IS
VERY MONUMENTAL AND YOU ARE ON
THE VANGUARD SIR SO CONGRATS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
THAT'S GREAT I DO HAVE A
QUESTION SO IS INDUSTRIAL HIM AN
ANNUAL OR PERENNIAL T'S AN
ANNUAL IT IS AN AND IT IS AN
ANNUAL YOU TO PLANT EVERY YEAR --
THEN AND I WANTED TO BUY YOUR
TIMES YOU CAN TELL ME TO BE
QUIET AT ANY POINT SELL -- TO
GIVE YOU A THIS YEAR BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW SEED IS. FOR NEXT YEAR
TO SEAT IS PROBABLY THE PLACE TO
BE. TO BE SELLING -- SEAT CAN
RANGE TYPICAL MOST CEDARS
RANGING ABOUT A DOLLAR TO TWO
DOLLARS PER SEED -- ORIGINALLY
WE WERE GOING TO TRY TO EASE
PLANT -- CLONES THIS YEAR --
BECAUSE ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WE
HAVE IS IS PLANTING CD END UP
WITH SOME MALES AND MALES WILL
END UP POLLINATING THE CROP AND
REALLY REDUCING THE YEAR QUALITY
OF THE CROP -- UNLESS YOU'RE
TRYING TO RAISE FOR SEED -- SO
WE'RE GONNA WITH CLONES THIS
YEAR AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
CLONES WENT FROM FOUR FIVE
DOLLARS PER PLANT. TO ABOUT
EIGHT DOLLARS A PLAN AND A HOT
THEY WERE PLAN ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND PLANTS PER ACRE AND
COLLECT ICAN'T DO THAT -- STILL --
BUT SEAT IS VIRTUALLY SOLD OUT
AT THIS POINT -- AND AND I'M
SURE WHEN CALIFORNIA SAYS THE
GATES ARE OPEN THAT -- HEADS
IT'S GOING TO BE SOLD OUT OF THE
DAY -- WERE IF THEY CAN FIND ANY
YES.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR
CAPPIELLO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO YOU YOU I
TESTIFIED THAT -- THAT HEMP IS A
HIGH INVESTMENT CROP IS IS THAT --
BECAUSE OF THE SEA.
YES MOSTLY BECAUSE OF THE SEED
COSTS -- BUT AND AND AND THE
LABOR -- TO UNTIL MECHANICAL
HARVESTING ESPECIALLY IS
AVAILABLE -- LABOR COSTS ARE
JUST.
A HUGE BECAUSE A LOT OF IT IS
DONE BY HAND RIGHT NOW.
BUT I THINK OVER THE NEXT YEAR
TOO THAT'S GOING TO START TO GET
FIGURED OUT -- THERE'S THERE'S
DIFFERENT METHODS COMING AROUND --
IT EVERYDAY I HEAR SOME GUY
INVENTED SOMETHING ELSE THE THE
TRY AND BUT BUT LABOR COSTS ARE
VERY HIGH ALSO.
AND THEN -- THOSE SEEDS.
I'M I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT --
ABOUT HOW YOU PLANT THEM OR OR
HOW THEY GROW -- ARE THEY HOT
HOUSED IN THEN YOU PLANT THE
PLANTS OR HOW HOW IS IT.
YEAH HE SAID YOU CAN DO IT
ANYWAY I MEAN I THINK FRANKLY IN
THE SALINAS VALLEY WHICH IS
WHERE I'M FROM -- THERE YOU THEY
USED TO PLANT LETTUCE WITH SEATS
AND NOW THOSE SEEDS DON'T.
DON'T SHOW UP ANYWHERE YOU HOT
HIGH HOUSING YOU BRING IT YOU
BRING IN THAT SMALL PLANTS THERE
PLANTED BY TRACTOR.
THAT JUST AUTOMATICALLY PUT THEM
IN THE GROUND IT'S AMAZING AND
SO I'M WONDERING HOW WHAT THE
APPLICATION IS IN TERMS OF HIM.
MOST OF THE HAMPER NOW HE IS
BEING TRANSPLANTED IN JUST LIKE
YOU SAID WITH THE MECHANICAL
MACHINES -- AND AND SO THEY
STILL START TO SEEDS IN IN THE
HOT HOUSES AND USUALLY THREE
FOUR WEEKS OF GROWTH AND THEN
THEY'LL START TRANSPLANTING --
BUT WE DID TRY LAST YEAR SOME
DIRECT SEEDING INTO THE FIELD --
AND IT WORKED OKAY -- AND SO I
THERE'S SOME TECHNOLOGY COMING
THAT'S JUST INCREDIBLE TO WHERE
THEY'RE TAKING TISSUE SAMPLES --
CULTURES I'M SORRY -- FROM
PLANTS -- TO WORDS.
AND AND IT'S JUST MICROSCOPIC
ALMOST AND THEY CAN CAPITALIZE
THEM AND THEN USE THAT AS YOUR
SEED AND SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
GROW THOSE IN A HOT HOUSE AND
YOU CAN PLAN OF DIRECT BUT AS OF
RIGHT NOW MOST OF THE CAMPUS
BEING PLANTED.
AS AS STARTER PLANTS AND THEN
BEING TRANSPLANTED.
SO IN THEORETICALLY -- AT SOME
POINT IF YOUR OPERATION IS IS
BIG ENOUGH YOU COULD ACTUALLY
REPRODUCE YOUR OWN PLANTS.
AND AND YOU COULD -- ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES IS GONNA COME IS --
IF I'M TRYING TO GROW FOR
EXAMPLE IF I'M TRYING TO GROW
FOR CBD OIL.
I WANT ALL FEMALE PLANTS I DON'T
WANNA POLLINATE ANY PLACE I
DON'T WANT SEATS ON A WINNING
WALL OF MY NEIGHBOR SAYS I WANNA
GO FOR SEED.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THERE'S CROSS
CONTAMINATION THERE THAT
POLLINATION IS GONNA AFFECT ME.
AND SAYS GIVE ME SOME REAL
CHALLENGES I THINK TO BE WORKED
OUT THROUGH SOME REGULATION --
MAYBE CRANE SOME SOME ZONES THAT
ARE YOU KNOW GIVEN SOME DISTANCE --
TO PROTECT THOSE GUYS BUT IS SO
pIT JUST DEPENDS WHAT WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING TO GROW -- BUT IT DID
THERE'S GOING TO BE SO THEY CAN
BE CHALLENGES WE'VE WE ALL KNOW
THAT -- THERE'S GONNA BE SOME
THAT WHEN YOU'RE STARTING TO
TALK ABOUT A BRAND NEW CROP HERE
AND TRYING TO YOUR COMMENTS
EARLIER ABOUT THE REGULATIONS --
YEAH -- AS A FARMER I DON'T WANT
ANYMORE REGULATIONS AND
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO HAVE AND YET
THERE'S GONNA NEED TO BE SOME TO
BE ABLE.
TO THE GUIDE FARMERS AND AND
GROWERS IN THE DIRECTION THAT
THE TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE THIS IN
A IN A PROPER WAY -- SO -- IT
BUT YEAH THERE'S GONNA BE SOME
SOME BUMPS.
YEAH WELL I APPRECIATE THAT I
I'VE MIKE MY MY A INTENSE
INTEREST IS THAT.
AS AS YOU SAID IT'S A NEW CROP --
BUT I AM.
IT IT'S NOT CLEAR.
TODAY AS WE SIT HERE WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH SIGMA.
AND WE HAVE.
LOT AGRICULTURE THIS GOING TO BE
IMPACTED -- AND IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE GOOD AND A GOOD IMPACT SO
THE MORE THAT WE CAN FIND
ALTERNATIVE.
CROPS AND THE ABILITY I'VE BEEN
TOLD --AND I'VE TALKED TO
SCIENTISTS FROM EUROPE THAT HAVE
BEEN GROWING HIM FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS.
THAT -- HIM HAS THE ABILITY TO
CLEAN THE SOIL.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS BECOMES
REALLY IMPORTANT WHAT'S THE
SCIENCE BEHIND IT AND HOW CAN WE
USE IT AND AND AND YET CONTINUE.
TO CONTINUE TO FARM YES SO THAT
THAT'S I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY AND AND YOUR
FORWARD THINKING THIS IN THE
RISK THAT YOU AND YOUR FAMILY
HAVE TAKEN BECAUSE IT'S NOT EASY
TO MOVE INTO SOMETHING THAT'S
TOTALLY DIFFERENT BUT I THINK
YOU ARE ON THE FOREFRONT OF
SOMETHING.
AND I'M I'M EXCITED ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I GO DOWN TO THAT THE
HEALTH FOOD STORE AND I BOUGHT
HIM SEE BECAUSE I WANTED TO SEE
MORE IT'S A HIGHEST SOURCE OF
PROTEIN.
AND IT COSTS A FORTUNE I MEAN
YOU COULDN'T LIVE ON HEMP SEEDS
BY THEMSELVES.
B. B. PRETTY SKINNY BUT BUT IT
IT IT IT'S INTERESTING TO ME
BECAUSE NOT ONLY IT IS IS IT A
COMMODITY YOU CAN EAT THAT HAS
BENEFICIAL HEALTH VALUE BUT IT
ALSO -- HAS THESE --
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE JUST SO
DIVERSE THAT IT IT IT'S
INTERESTING AND I WANT I WANT TO
SEE CALIFORNIA BE ON THE
FOREFRONT I WANT TO SEE AS
NORMALIZE IT AS A CROP.
I GUESS IS THE WAY THAT I I SEE
IT AND I DO APPRECIATE THERE
PROBABLY IS GOING TO NEED TO BE
REGULATION GIVEN THAT YOU CAN.
YOU CAN CROSS POLLINATED YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE AFFECTING.
ARE YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
IMPACTING YOUR NEIGHBOR IN A
NEGATIVE WAY AND SO I I
APPRECIATE THAT AND WE DO IT WE
DO IT WITH THEM.
WITH CERTIFIED ORGANICS ANYWAY
SO I'M I'M SURE WE CAN WE CAN
GET TO A PLACE THAT EVERYBODY
FEELS IS A COMFORTABLE PLACE
THERE WILL BE AWAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THAT IF WE HAVE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
AND OUR THIRD PANEL.
DEALING WITH ADVOCACY FOR
GROWING INDUSTRIAL HIM WE HAVE
EIGHTY BERNACCHI DIRECTOR AND
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HIM COUNCIL AS WELL
AS PATRICK GROGAN GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE CALIFORNIA HIM
COUNCIL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ANYONE I CAN
MAP THE CALIFORNIA HAVE COUNSEL --
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL IS A
COALITION OF HEMP -- CULTIVATORS
MANUFACTURERS AND PRODUCT
PRODUCERS -- WHO HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO CREATE A COUNCIL TO
PROMOTE AND PROTECT THE HEALTH
INDUSTRY FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
AND REGULATORY PERSPECTIVE?
AND SO IT'S VERY EXCITING THAT
THE INDUSTRY IS TRYING TO
FORMULATE -- IN A LARGER WAY TO
PROTECT ITSELF AND PROMOTE
ITSELF IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- ONE START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY --
IT'S VERY REFRESHING TO SEE SUCH
INTEREST.
AND INDUSTRIAL HEMP AND HOW WE
CAN PROMOTE IT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- YOU MANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE AT AND
CRITICALLY INVOLVED.
IN -- CITY CALIFORNIA POSITION
ITSELF TO BENEFIT FROM THE HEMP
INDUSTRY SO -- I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU AND START OFF WITH
THAT -- HIPPA THE BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY -- IS ANTICIPATED TO
DOUBLE.
AND BY THE END OF NEXT YEAR.
AND COMPARED TO SOME OF OUR
NEIGHBORING STATES LIKE OREGON --
COLORADO MONTANA CALIFORNIA HAS
FALLEN BEHIND THE CURVE IN
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS THE INDUSTRY WILL
PROVIDE FROM AN AGRICULTURAL
STANDPOINT.
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
AGRICULTURE AT LAST YEAR OREGON
PRODUCED.
SEVENTY EIGHT HUNDRED ACRES OF
HEMP -- COLORADO PRODUCED.
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND ACRES OF
HAPPY IN MONTANA PRODUCE TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND ACRES OF LAND FOR
HIM FOR COMMERCIAL USE.
CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIALLY PRODUCED --
ZERO ALTHOUGH WE ESTIMATE THAT
ABOUT SEVENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
ACRES OF HAVE WAS GROWN IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BY ESTABLISH
AGRICULTURAL RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS -- BUT YOU CAN SEE
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO --
IN AHEAD OF US TO GET CALIFORNIA --
WHERE IT SHOULD BE -- IT'S
RIGHTFUL PLACE AS THE
AGRICULTURAL CAPITAL OF THIS
COUNTRY -- THE NEED TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA STATUTES ARE UP TO
DATE COMPATIBLE WITH FEDERAL LAW
IS OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE --
CENTER WILK A IS VERY AWARE OF
THIS IS HE'S BEEN THE AUTHOR OF
THE MOST RECENT EFFORTS -- IN
THIS AREA -- THIS EAR -- WERE
SPONSORING -- WITH THEIR WORK AS
THE AUTHOR SB ONE FIVE THREE I
BELIEVE THE CHAIR IN CENTER
CABALLERO BOTH CO AUTHORS OF
THAT MEASURE -- YOU KNOW WITH
AND THAT BILL WILL UPDATE
CALIFORNIA'S LEGISLATIVE
FRAMEWORK SO THE GOLDEN STATE
CAN APPLY -- FOR IMPROVE STATE
PLAN UNDER THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FARM BILL -- AND GET
HAVE CULTIVATION GOING HERE IN
THE STATE ON A LARGE SCALE -- TO
THAT I HAVE WITH ME.
TODAY MISTER PATRICK GARGAN
GOGGIN HE'S A CHIEF LEGAL
COUNSEL TO THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL -- TO PROVIDE A QUICK
OVERVIEW OF WHAT WILL TAKE TO
GET LEGISLATIVELY -- DO YOU GET
CALIFORNIA'S FEDERAL YOU KNOW
FEDERAL PLAN OUR STATE PLAN UP
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND APPROVED AND UPDATE OUR
STRUCTURE -- AND WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AN
ALTERNATIVE PATRICK TO KIND OF
GUIDE YOU THROUGH THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LOG IN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I YOU KNOW I JUST
WANT TO SAY.
AT THE OUTSET THAT TODAY'S
MONUMENTAL.
WE'VE BEEN WHAT IT IS THE C. H.
C. THE CALIFORNIA HIM COUNCIL
CONTINUES THE GOOD WORK OF VOTE
HAND THAT VOTE HEMP HAS BEEN
LEADING.
HAS LED US SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIVE WITH THE AND ASSEMBLY
pSENATOR LANA -- AND IT'S ALSO
MONUMENTAL BECAUSE WE WE ARE ON
THE CUSP OF REGISTRATIONS BEING
AVAILABLE AND I WANNA I WANNA.
IN AND COMPLEMENT THE GOOD WORK
OF CDFA AND IT'S IT'S RESILIENCE
IN THE FACE OF A LOT OF
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING TO OVERCOME FOR AFTER
EIGHTY YEARS OF PROHIBITING.
AN AGRICULTURAL CROP IS IS IT
THAT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE
WE'VE WE'VE STIGMATIZED THAT
WE'VE PUT IT IN THE CAMP OF A
DRUG AND NOW WE CAN SAY IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT.
STORY IS OVER AND WE'RE
TRANSITIONING TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IS A TRANSITION EVERY
YEAR WHERE BY THE BY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE FULL COMMERCIAL SCALE
CAMPING GROWN IN THIS COUNTRY.
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
FIFTIES AND THAT IS MONEY NOW
[inaudible]
SO ON I'M GONNA GO THROUGH
REALLY BRIEFLY A FEW OF THE
THINGS THAT TO THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FARM BILL DOES WITHIN
ITS HEMP PRODUCTION SECTION AND
THEN WHAT WHAT IS CALIFORNIA
DOING -- IN ANTICIPATION OF THAT
ON IT TO GET ITS PROGRAM --
FURTHER -- AND STATUTES AND
REGULATIONS FURTHER DEVELOPED TO
CONFORM WITH THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FARM BILL SO JUST TO TO
REPEAT A COUPLE THINGS HEY.
THE US DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURAL APPROPRIATELY NOW
HAS JURISDICTION THE
JURISDICTION OF THE D. E. A. HAS
GONE AWAY I AM I I AM JUST TRULY
HAPPY TODAY THAT THAT I'M NOT
BEING CHASED AROUND THE CAPITAL
BY JOHN LEVEL.
WELL AS I DO.
BOND IT'S IT'S IT'S A NEW DAY.
SO USDA HAS BEEN TASKED WITH
PROMULGATING REGULATIONS THERE
IN THE MIDST OF THE DAY THEY HAD
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
THEMSELVES -- A MONTH OR SO AGO
AND THEY THINK THAT LATER THIS
YEAR HOPEFULLY BY THE END OF THE
YEAR HOPEFULLY MAYBE THIS
SOMETIME IN THE FALL THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE REGULATIONS --
ISSUED BY THE U. S. T. A. THAT
WILL ENABLE THEM TO APPROVE
STATE PLANS AND TO CREATE A PLAN
FOR STATES THAT DON'T SUBMIT
STATE PLANS.
AND SIGNIFICANTLY THERE ARE
SEVEN MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS THAT
THE STATE BILL NEEDS
[inaudible]
TO MEET.
NUMBER ONE I'LL JUST GO THROUGH
KIND OF QUICKLY WHAT THOSE ARE
NUMBER ONE IT'S IT'S A PRACTICE
TO TRACK WHERE HELP IS BEING
CROWNED AND THAT'S THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT -- THING THAT HAS
THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED IN OUR
STATUTE THROUGH REGISTRATION NOT
pLICENSING -- REQUIREMENTS -- FOR
FOR THINGS LIKE -- THE THE
NURSERIES AND AND WHAT NOT BUT
IT WAS IMPORTANT THAT THIS BE
REGISTRATION PROGRAM NOT A
LICENSE PROGRAM TO DISTINGUISH
IT FROM.
FROM CANNABIS -- SECOND THERE'S
A THERE'S NEEDS TO BE PROCEDURES
FOR TESTING OF CROPS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY COMPLY WITH THE
T. C. LIMITATIONS AT POINT 3%
AND AS PART OF THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE A CONSIDERATION.
FOR POST DECARBOXYLATION OR
SIMILARLY RELIABLE METHODS WHICH
WHICH ESSENTIALLY MEANS THAT TCA
THE ACIDIC VERSION OF T. C.
NEEDS TO BE ACCOUNTED FOR AND
THERE'S AND THERE'S A AN
EQUATION FOR THAT.
THIRD THERE NEEDS TO BE A
PROCESS FOR DISPOSING OF NON
COMPLIANT CROPS PLANTS AND
PRODUCTS.
NUMBER FOUR THERE NEEDS TO BE A
PROCEDURE FOR COMPLYING WITH.
CERTAIN IT ENFORCEMENT
PROCEDURES THAT ARE LAID OUT IN
THE FARM BILL. FOR VIOLATING THE
PROGRAM.
AND SOMETHING THAT WE WE WORKED
HARD AGAINST IT BUT ULTIMATELY
IT IT WAS A COMPROMISE THAT WAS
ADOPTED AND AND THE THIRD IS A
LIMITATION.
ON FOLKS WHO'VE BEEN CONVICTED
OF A FELONY. FOR THE PRIOR TEN
YEARS THAT THEY CAN NOT THEY'RE
NOT ELIGIBLE.
NUMBER FIVE IS THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE ANNUAL INSPECTIONS AND
RANDOM SAMPLING PERFORMED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD IN AG.
NUMBER SIX THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE A TIMELY SUBMITTAL TO THE U.
S. T. A..
BUY THE CD F. A. OF EACH PERMITS
LOCATION AND STATUS.
WHETHER IT'S ACTIVE OR INACTIVE
IT'S BEEN.
REVOKED WHAT HAVE YOU AND
FINALLY THE STATE NEEDS TO
CERTIFY.
THAT IT HAS THE RESOURCES AND
CAPABILITY TO CARRY OUT THE
PROGRAM.
ALSO INCLUDED WITHIN -- THE THE
STATUTE.
JUST A COUPLE OF POINTS IT DOES
AUTHORIZED CROP INSURANCE -- AND
THE THE GRANTING OF USDA GRANTS.
THERE THERE.
THERE WAS SOME CONCERN AND IS
SOME CONCERN ON THE CROP
INSURANCE BY.
FOLKS LIKE THE CONGRESSIONAL
RESEARCH SERVICE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PROPER STANDARDS ARE
ADOPTED SO THAT THE INSURANCE
CARRIERS ARE NOT EXPLOITING OUR
FARMERS.
AND THAT'S BEING WORKED THERE AS
A ALL THESE ISSUES IS ARE ARE
ARE BEING WORKED THROUGH AND AND
SIGNIFICANTLY AND IMPORTANTLY IN
WAS WAS A TO RELATED.
REFERRED TO EARLIER IS THAT THE
THAT THE BILL [inaudible]
PROHIBITS STATES.
FROM.
STOPPING.
THE TRANSPORTATION OF TEN
THROUGH THEIR STATES THEY CAN
PROHIBIT THE PRODUCTION BUT THEY
CANNOT STOP THE TRANSPORTATION
OF HIM THROUGH THEIR STATES
THAT'S THAT'S TRULY IMPORTANT
THAT'S BECOME A GROUP OF A
SIGNIFICANT -- AND PROBLEMS AND
CHALLENGE.
SINCE THE 200-020-0014 FARM BILL
WHICH AUTHORIZES COMMERCIAL
ACTIVITY IT'S IT'S LIMITED TO
NEEDS TO BE TIED TO RESEARCH BUT
HIS CREATED.
THESE THESE THIS PATCHWORK QUILT
OF STATE LAWS THROUGHOUT THE THE
NATION HAVE CREATED A CHALLENGE
PRODUCT AROUND AND AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE NEED.
TO WE HONOR AND ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE THAT THE GOVERNMENT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS CREATING A
PATHWAY THROUGHOUT THE NATION
FOR CALIFORNIA.
SO UNTIL THE STATE PLANS ARE
APPROVED WE STAY AND WE ARE
REMAIN UNDER THE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN FARM BILL AS WE
TRANSITION TO THE FULL
COMMERCIAL SCALE WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THE MEANTIME IS WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
GET REGULATIONS IN PLACE SO THAT
THIS PILOT PROGRAM CAN.
PROCEED IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AND GET US TO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE WE GET BEYOND THE
PILOT PROGRAM SO.
SB ONE FIVE THREE THAT
EVERYBODY'S FAMILIAR WITH IS A
LARGELY TECHNICAL BUILD WORKING
TO CONFORM TO THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FARM BUILT AND MEET
THESE MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS AS
WELL AS HAND.
THAT AT SOME POINT -- I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW WHERE WE'RE AT WITH
THIS BUT WE NEED TO ALSO HAVE A
TRIGGER AND AND A MECHANISM FOR
GETTING THE HELP FROM THE FARM.
TO THE PROCESSING FACILITY
THROUGH HANDLERS AND AND BROKERS
AND THIS WILL BE A VEHICLE FOR
THAT THE OTHER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION -- THAT'S WORKING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE IS AB
TWO TWO EIGHT AND THAT THAT IS
PRINCIPALLY WORKING TO BOTH
DECLARE.
HAND EXTRACTED OILS FROM THE
FLOWERS NOT TO BE AN ADULTERANT
THAT'S BEEN A BIG.
CONCERNED AND ISSUE RAISED BY
THE FDA AND WE'RE HERE TO SAY
AND WE'VE BEEN HERE TO SAY THAT
HAD THAT THESE PRODUCTS ARE SAFE
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
HAS SAID THAT THEY'RE SAFE.
IT'S A MATTER OF HOW THEY ARE.
PROP PRODUCED AND THAT THEY NEED
TO BE DONE IN A WAY THAT'S THAT
THAT THE EMPLOYEES GOOD
MANUFACTURING PRACTICES AND THE
SAME TYPE OF THING THAT AND AND
END PROCESS SEES THAT ALL FOOD
MANUFACTURERS ARE.
HELD TO ACCOUNT FOR AND LET'S
LET'S JUST LET'S JUST SAY.
THIS IS A VEGETABLE AND WE NEED
TO BE TO BE DEALING WITH THE AS
A VESSEL REGULATING IT AS A
VEGETABLE AS A FOOD.
AND AS A DIETARY SUPPLEMENT AS A
COP AS A TOPICAL AND THE
COSMETIC NOT AS A DRUG IF
SOMEONE WANTS TO GET INTO THE
THE PHARMACEUTICAL APPLICATION
OF THIS THEN THEY CAN WORK WITH
THE FDA TO DO THAT.
WE AS AN INDUSTRY ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE FDA TO TO MOVE
BE ON TO ITS ITS POSITION ON CBT
DERIVED FROM CANNABIS AND THEY
ARE WORKING WITH THE INDUSTRY
AND CONGRESS TO CREATE.
OUR ALTERNATIVE PATHWAYS
RECOGNIZE ALTERNATIVE PATHWAYS
FOR THESE PRODUCTS IN THE
NUTRACEUTICAL SPACE.
BUT SIGNIFICANTLY WHAT AB TWO
TWO EIGHT WILL DO IS GIVE CITY
P. H. THE AUTHORITY IT NEEDS TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR PRODUCTS ARE
SAFE FOR OUR CONSUMERS.
SO WITH THAT ALL LEAVE IT TO ANY
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE --
BUT AGAIN WE GREATLY APPRECIATE.
THIS VENUE TODAY. TO PROVIDE
FURTHER INFORMATION ON HOW
PROGRESS AND IN THE STATE IN THE
NATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY I APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONYVERY MUCH.
AND DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE AUDIENCE OR ANY
COMMENTS.
OKAY WITH THAT WE HAVE.
WE HAVE NO MORE BUSINESS BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
WE WILL [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
OTHER THAN LIFTING THE CALL ON
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US TODAY VOTE FOR TO HAVING YOU
AT OUR NEXT HEARING THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY
.
OKAY WILL THE SECRETARY PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE CONSENT
SENATOR GLAZERS.
GLAZER II.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS OF OUR
HEARING